dès la première année le festival
n'aurait jamais pu exister sans la
martinique sans la guadeloupe
ils ont été les premiers à venir ce qui
est assez merveilleux pour nous c'est
qu'ils sont toujours là vingt-et-une
session après et c'est un peu la même
chose pour le tourisme en général les
antilles et français font encore sont
encore numéro un dans la partie
arrivages autorise la culture est une
part intégrante du produit touristique
en tout cas on dominique est depuis
toujours
ça fait vraiment d'ailleurs c'est
tellement une part intégrante
qu'aujourd'hui le festival représente
une des grosses parties d'arrivage du
nombre de touristes annuels
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette 21e
édition
elle est encore plus ambitieuse que les
années précédentes c'est une progression
pour la dominique
donc qu'est-ce qu'on attend d'abord
comme d'habitude que tout se passe bien
mais ça aujourd'hui on est assez
confiant là dessus c'est pas notre
première édition et en général tout se
passe très bien
ensuite ce qu'on attend c'est que les
martiniquais viennent en masse il ya
maintenant une liaison aérienne donc
c'est encore plus simple qu'avant et on
attend encore plus de participants de la
martinique qui vont de plus en plus se
reconnaître se sentir chez eux entre la
guadeloupe et et et la martinique et à
la dominique
c'est là que les guadeloupéens et les
martiniquais se retrouvent